efe
[Music]
mons
at the time I started to make this
mask now the age is not
good santiago 16 I was already a professional
my name a vegetable garden lópez I am a
designer craftsman the carnival mask
[Music]
hello
making the cart is quite difficult
Although it takes quite a bit of procedure, it
really begins to be a very weak
bar,
then a cow's chewing gum is produced, a chewing gum is
made so that the mold is made whenever
you want in plaster,
the starch is made from cassava,
then the process is done by adding a
little vinegar,
milk, water.  it is taken to the stove and then
it dissolves
the masks are fun
[Music]
because they are two traditions or jennifer
money and the mold that the pepineros
use a mouth as if it were a
grass that is why the cove has been called space
pp rajoy  It was a very small thing, little
deer, having horns, they already
increased him with that, he knows how to be,
the pot distinguished himself,
the mask that I make, the lesson groups ask me for them
,
my name is the moral wind and
c technician  arnaval de santiago
my person is the fact is the
central character of carnival de santiago figure is
the fantasy money that is produced that
ends the mirror feathers and all those
things what I like the most and that you do not see
in santiago are the colorful ones the
floats are what  that motivates me to
dress up
when I get injured with a mask from the
table I say wow look how humberto
lópez was how his culture is advancing and they
change every day
[Music]